four times as many female fighter pilots
in the U.S Air Force as there are male
kindergarten teachers in the USA by
percentage by percentage Yeah two
percent of kindergarten teachers are
male and eight percent of U.S Air Force
fighter pilots are female now I'm
perfectly happy to have a conversation
about whether there should be more
female fighter pilots but there
definitely should be more male
kindergarten teachers as well wait why
do you think there should be more more
male kindergarten teachers because they
serve as a very good role model to both
deal with boisterous boys and also
educate them effectively I think that
the educational outcomes that you get
from young boys especially when they
have a male teacher seem to be better
and if you are only getting a 1 in 50
chance that you're ever going to deal
with a male teacher as a young boy
kindergarten though correct